The probability axioms
are the basic rules
of probability theory.
And they are surprisingly few.
But they imply many interesting
properties that we
will now explore.
First we will see that what you
might think of as missing
axioms are actually implied by
the axioms already in place.
For example, we have an axiom
that probabilities are
non-negative.
We will show that probabilities
are also less
than or equal to 1.
We have another axiom that says
that the probability of
the entire sample space is 1.
We will show a counterpart that
the probability of the
empty set is equal to 0.
This makes perfect sense.
The empty set has no elements,
so it is impossible.
There is 0 probability that the
outcome of the experiment
would lie in the empty set.
We also have another
intuitive property.
The probability that an event
happens plus the probability
that the vendor does not
happen exhaust all
possibilities.
And these two probabilities
together should add to 1.
For instance, if the probability
of heads is 0.6,
then the probability of
tails should be 0.4.
Finally, we can generalize the
additivity axiom, which was
originally given for the case of
two disjoint events to the
case where we're dealing
with the union of
several disjoint events.
By disjoint here we mean that
the intersection of any two of
these events is the empty set.
We will prove this for the case
of three events and then
the argument generalizes for
the case where we're taking
the union of k disjoint
events, where k
is any finite number.
So the intuition of this result
is the same as for the
case of two events.
But we will derive it formally
and we will also use it to
come up with a way of
calculating the probability of
a finite set by simply adding
the probabilities of its
individual elements.
All of these statements
that we just
presented are intuitive.
And you do not to really
need to be
convinced about their validity.
Nevertheless, it is instructive
to see how these
statements follow from
the axioms that
we have put in place.
So we will now present the
arguments based only on the
three axioms that we
have available.
And in order to be able to refer
to these axioms, let us
give them some names, call
them axioms A, B, and C.
We start as follows.
Let us look at the sample space
and a subset of that
sample space.
Call it A. And consider the
complement of that subset.
The complement is the set of
all elements that do not
belong to the set A. So a set
together with its complement
make up everything, which is
the entire sample space.
On the other hand, if an element
belongs to a set A, it
does not belong to
its complement.
So the intersection of a
set with its complement
is the empty set.
Now we argue as follows.
We have that the probability of
the entire sample space is
equal to 1.
This is true by our
second axiom.
Now the sample space, as we just
discussed, can be written
as the union of an event and the
complement of that event.
This is just a set theoretic
relation.
And next since a set and its
complement our disjoint, this
means that we can apply the
additivity axiom and write
this probability as the sum of
the probability of event A
with the probability of the
complement of A. This is one
of the relations that we had
claimed and which we have now
established.
Based on this relation, we
can also write that the
probability of an event A
is equal to 1 minus the
probability of the complement
of that event.
And because, by the
non-negativity axiom this
quantity here is non-negative, 1
minus something non-negative
is less than or equal to 1.
We're using here the
non-negativity axiom.
And we have established another
property, namely that
probabilities are always less
than or equal to 1.
Finally, let us note that 1 is
the probability, always, of a
set plus the probability of
a complement of that set.
And let us use this property for
the case where the set of
interest is the entire
sample space.
Now, the probability of the
entire sample space is itself
equal to 1.
And what is the complement of
the entire sample space?
The complement of the entire
sample space consists of all
elements that do not belong
to the sample space.
But since the sample space is
supposed to contain all
possible elements,
its complement is
just the empty set.
And from this relation we get
the implication that the
probability of the empty
set is equal to 0.
This establishes yet one more of
the properties that we had
just claimed a little earlier.
We finally come to the proof of
the generalization of our
additivity axiom from the case
of two disjoint events to the
case of three disjoint events.
So we have our sample space.
And within that sample
space we have three
events, three subsets.
And these subsets are disjoint
in the sense that any two of
those subsets have no
elements in common.
And we're interested in the
probability of the union of A,
B, and C.
How do we make progress?
We have an additivity axiom in
our hands, which applies to
the case of the union of
two disjoint sets.
Here we have three of them.
But we can do the
following trick.
We can think of the union of A,
B, and C as consisting of
the union of this blue set
with that green set.
Formally, what we're doing is
that we're expressing the
union of these three
sets as follows.
We form one set by taking the
union of A with B. And we have
the other set C. And the overall
union can be thought
of as the union of
these two sets.
Now since the three sets are
disjoint, this implies that
the blue set is disjoint from
the green set and so we can
use the additivity axiom here
to write this probability as
the probability of A union B
plus the probability of C. And
now we can use the additivity
axiom once more since the sets
A and B are disjoint to write
the first term as probability
of A plus probability of B. We
carry over the last term and
we have the relation that
we wanted to prove.
This is the proof for the
case of three events.
You should be able to follow
this line of proof to write an
argument for the case of
four events and so on.
And you might want to continue
by induction.
And eventually you should be
able to prove that if the sets
A1 up to Ak are disjoint then
the probability of the union
of those sets is going to be
equal to the sum of their
individual probabilities.
So this is the generalization
to the case where we're
dealing with the union of
finitely many disjoint events.
A very useful application of
this comes in the case where
we want to calculate the
probability of a finite set.
So here we have a
sample space.
And within that sample space
we have some particular
elements S1, S2, up
to Sk, k of them.
And these elements together
form a finite set.
What can we say about
the probability
of this finite set?
The idea is to take this finite
set that consists of k
elements and think of it as the
union of several little
sets that contain one
element each.
So set theoretically what we're
doing is that we're
taking this set with k elements
and we write it as
the union of a set that contains
just S1, a set that
contains just the second element
S2, and so on, up to
the k-th element.
We're assuming, of course, that
these elements are all
different from each other.
So in that case, these sets,
these single element sets, are
all disjoint.
So using the additivity property
for a union of k
disjoint sets, we can write
this as the sum of the
probabilities of the different
single element sets.
At this point, it is usual to
start abusing, or rather,
simplifying notation
a little bit.
Probabilities are assigned
to sets.
So here we're talking about the
probability of a set that
contains a single element.
But intuitively, we can also
talk as just the probability
of that particular element and
use this simpler notation.
So when using the simpler
notation, we will be talking
about the probabilities of
individual elements.
Although in terms of formal
mathematics, what we really
mean is the probability of this
event that's comprised
only of a particular element
S1 and so on.